you know what you have to do
i came here to seduce your father just
in case he didn't do the right thing
kelly kapowski kelly
hey zach
it's okay big dance friday night huh i
haven't asked anyone yet zack really
well i just want you to know that i'm
keeping my calendar clear you know what
i mean i know what you mean you want me
to ask you you could do worse she could
do better
a lot better now our next couple is the
morris kapowskis i'm an old-fashioned
girl mrs morris would be fine
huh
kelly morris
wow
i've died and gone to heaven i am so
glad i found you i have to talk to you
oh
i wonder what it could be i don't want
to go to the dance with slater
what
listen it gets better i suddenly
realized how much i care for you sad
please rescue me from this muscle-bound
monkey
well kelly how can you say that you're
wearing my heart this thing who cares
please say you go to the dance with me
zack
okay i'll go with you
what are you guys doing here kelly we
can't wait any longer we've come for
your answer that's right next week is a
prom and you've got to choose between us
right oh come on i like you both
i don't want to hurt either one of you
why if you want to hurt slater it's okay
hey
why would she want to go with a boy when
she can go with a gladiator
guys this is hard it's like choosing
between two great pieces of chocolate
sorry kelly from now on you only get
zits from one of us
okay if i must
you must
i want my mommy
hey she can go with zach
listen i'll give you my answer in the
morning okay
all right then
kelly
[Music]
well she's young and vulnerable let her
down gently got it yeah right gently
sails like the guys really hang up on
your sister and you'd be much better off
with someone else
hi it's zach look i'm the one running
the teen line and you're the only
kapowski i care about but don't tell
your sister she let her down gently
don't worry zack i won't tell kelly
nikki
zack what are you doing here what am i
doing here i came to see you
well you kind of picked an awkward time
zack
i'd like you to meet melvin nerdly
you're a melvin nerdly
see you tomorrow kelly all right
it was a great idea about dating other
people zack tonight melvin taught me
chess tomorrow he's teaching me lambada
thanks
uh look kelly i've been acting crazy
recently
but now i'm back to normal
i want to go out with you and nobody
else
zack i adore your innocence
when two nuts in a forest are dating
other nuts they can't go steady with
each other good night
oh
wait kelly oh come on kelly
go away or you'll be sorry it kind of
just butt out okay i warned you
kelly do you realize we've been going
steady for 68 days 14 hours and 37
minutes 38 minutes zach but then again
who's counting
jeff i just got this job i couldn't ask
for time off already if you'd like to go
take the night off it's okay with me
are you sure you're not gonna miss me
here of course i'm gonna miss you i
always miss you when you're gone
you do
you're terrific kelly
you too jeff
you know you're the nicest guy i've met
in a long time
oh
i better get going i'll see you tomorrow
kelly are you okay
no i'm not
it is so weird i mean i'm here with zach
and he's the greatest guy
but all i can think about is jeff the
king and queen of the costume ball are
[Music]
romeo and juliet zach and kelly
[Applause]
kelly you're the most beautiful queen
i've ever seen thanks jeff
i know there's something going on
between you and jeff
please just talk to me
i don't know how to say this
it's just that jeff and i have been
working together
and do you really like him
no
yes
i don't know
it's just all happening so fast
kelly what happened i i thought you
loved me
i do love you zach
it wasn't supposed to be this way
not for us
i didn't want to hurt you for anything
in the whole world
i thought we'd always be together
i'm so sorry
i miss you kelly
[Music]
good morning zach
no matter how hard you try you'll never
forget me
forget you
i don't even know your name kelly
oh my gosh she's pretty
i know this girl who would love to go
out with you her name is sue and besides
being pretty she's got a great mind and
she loves to read so she's got a lot to
say
you've got to go out with cassie you
never met my cousin kimberly did you
well this is the place
hey look who's here hi zach
oh hi oh i'm glad you're here can you
get us a table something really romantic
yeah sure right this way
see you guys later
wow look at him come on zach let me
order let's split a milkshake
one chocolate milkshake with
two straws
i'm sorry for the way i treated you
i guess i was more hurt than i thought
and i didn't know how to deal with it
i noticed
you are a very hard girl to get over
kelly
but i'd rather have you as a friend than
not have you at all
oh zach
hey congratulations jeff
you got a great girl
treat her right
yeah you got it man
oh besides this place bites kelly we
were just leaving right guys
i thought this was a happening place to
be i mean everybody comes here yes kelly
unfortunately everybody comes here
i broke up with a great guy for you
you're very special to me
but i'm just not ready for a commitment
right now
i'm sorry
yeah well i'm sorry i fell for dishonest
jerk like you goodbye
yeah it's getting colder
just kiss that's what it felt like to me
uh kelly i didn't i know
me neither
we've had fun together again haven't we
oh yeah
[Music]
even though
huh
oh you were saying even though i was
it was probably nothing
oh well that's enough talk for now what
don't you guys just look at each other
and have a visual relationship
no zack she wants to date other guys not
just you
oops
is that true i mean you just want to be
friends
i hope that's okay
oh it's great i was gonna say the same
thing see i told you he'd be destroyed
hi
zack moore senior welcoming committee oh
please call me zac and please call me
tonight
i'll pitch on the speed dial
do you want anything else man no thanks
when you smile at me like that
i got everything i need
matt you're embarrassing me
i'm using ketchup
can i tell you a minute sure is that
do you mind
demon
uh
look i've been thinking a lot about the
prom and there are a lot of girls i
could ask but when it comes down to it
there's just one girl i want to go with
now she's the only girl i've ever cared
about
uh
what i'm trying to say is kelly will you
be my date for the senior prom
zack that's so sweet
well then you will
i can't
i've already said yes to matt wilson
i'm sorry i hope there's no hard
feelings don't be ridiculous i'm happy
for you but i feel it's my duty
as a fellow guy
to warn you
about what about meeting kelly's old man
see he's very protective he used to
interrogate prisoners of war and
sometimes
oh man he gets carried away
sounds dangerous
actually he's a limp compared to kelly's
two older brothers he'll break your hand
if you try to touch her
are you serious oh yeah i mean you see
how this thumb bends
oh
you used to be able to do this
you know i'm really getting excited
about going to the prom
uh-huh
listen would you mind picking me up a
little early you know my father wants to
meet you
he does
what about your brothers oh they'll be
there too i mean the whole family wants
to meet you
oh no
i just remembered i asked somebody else
at the prom before i asked you i'm such
a dummy well if she said yes sir i gotta
take her you understand well hope you
find somebody else bye
but i i really hate to butt in but i
couldn't help overhearing he dumped me i
feel like such a fool
no no no he's the fool
look
my office still stands why don't you go
to the prom with me
zack
i mean you're always there when
something bad happens
i'd love to be your date really
ellie i'm i'm sorry i just couldn't see
us going to the senior prom any other
way but together
i've been too big a part of my life
exactly i know i know it's supposed to
be over between us and i know we're
friends now but
kelly
i don't feel that way
you're the only girl for me and you
always will be
maybe what you did was wrong
but this feels right
i think we belong together too
zach and kelly two people destined for
each other
what's up we're back
[Applause]
i didn't know you guys were coming oh
it's homecoming weekend
yeah
i wish we could have seen the game but
on the way here we got a flat tire
do you hear your son we have raised a
real prankster turned activist like
george clooney hmm
now those parents suck you know the
douglas kids they deserve to go to a
great school like bayside but besides
new kids keep things fresh remember tori
who
do i know my father
of course it's zach
why are you asking you're
you're not jeffs
so last night was fun yeah it's just
like old times
except like
not fun and really not like old times
why was it so weird
were we being too sexy ah we're always
too sexy we got all the awkwardness out
of the way i bet tonight is gonna be
great man it is so hot when you're
cheerful and optimistic i'm so glad
you're the only woman i've ever been
with in my entire
life it's